dating app bumble saw its shares soar in
its thursday ipo
making 31 year old ceo and co-founder
whitney wolf heard
the world's youngest self-made women
billionaire
her 11.6 stake in the company was worth
1.5 billion
at the end of trading thursday and to
top it off
wolf herd is also the youngest female
ceo ever to take a company public in the
us
shares of the stock opened at 76 much
higher than its initial ipo price of
dollars per share as a result of the
public offering
the austin-based company raised 2.2
billion dollars
most of the funds raised in the offering
will be used to purchase or redeem
shares from its pre-ipo
owners namely private equity firm
blackstone
which owned nearly 91 before the
offering
and wolf herd bumble is the second
biggest dating app to go public
ever after match group's 2015 ipo bumble
reported 417 million dollars in revenue
in the first nine months of 2020
up from 363 million dollars over the
same time
frame in 2019. at 76
a share early thursday afternoon
bumble's market cap was 8.6 billion
dollars